you know I feel like with everything
that's happening
um and a lot of the dumb conversations
that are happening I thought there was
one thing that was really interesting to
me what during that live stream that
they did one thing that they said last
day Ethan Klein and his wife oh okay
yeah cool whatever
um they said something they said oh look
at these centrists and they went air
quotes they're centrists you know yeah
yeah and we know what that means kind of
um like I said I don't know enough about
them right which is essentially like
their way of being like we know what
that means so that's what they said
right which is another way of saying
like we're like alt right right Wingers
it's not it's not no I think it means
that the word Centrist reviews like
people or view like people that are not
solid and not flip-flop that's not how
they meant it no when they say when they
say strangers like this with oh yeah
that's what you're saying they're trying
to say they're not actually they're
saying we're right right yeah yeah
you're right you're right I just noticed
this the irony of all this whole thing
is that politically speaking if we're
being like just straight
we have way more in common with these
two people than we would with anyone on
the right right if you were to ask us on
all our policies and be like yo we're
for socialized Healthcare yeah I mean
I'll speak for me social science
Healthcare yeah I'm for taxation for
social programs and four unions I'm Four
Strong labor laws I'm for immigration
that allows people to come in reasonably
uh you know so on a lot of the major
Court I'm for Public Funding for
Education that's very strong I believe
in like I believe in a lot of
socialization for society to be a
cohesive you may disagree that's okay we
don't come to this channel to all agree
on one thing but this is something I've
noticed since my early 20s you can be
left-leaning in all the most important
categories and these people be like oh
my God cultural war and it's all these
people ever talk about why is this
obsession with culture War but then if
you say one thing like yo
I don't think trans women should be able
to miss Sports yo look at this
right-wing conservative bigot
come on what the minute you go on one
the internet have to be on that topic
specifically but if you want one thing
no matter what the thing is yeah
when they say stuff like that you like
do you realize that most of the people
who are black who voted Democrat
align with exactly what I'm saying yeah
are they also all right-wing operatives
oh well you know what me personally I
think there's some ways in which
feminism has worked against women's
interests you're right
did I ever say that I was in pro-choice
did I ever say like on the important
stuff but we can't just disagree and I
noticed that
I mean this could be true for everyone
but I noticed as someone who leads left
people look at you it's not that you're
an imperfect Ally you're just an enemy
the moment you disagree you're not like
an ally who I disagree with you're not
like this person on the same team who we
just have a different Vision to some
degree
you're an enemy immediately yeah you're
gonna be in a whole ass box
they did there's no there's no Nuance
it's funny how like I counted all right
the other day I was looking at my cell
phone and they are
more than 10 applications on my phones
that are meant for communication okay
over ten that's without the text
messaging and the phone calls which
that's what a phone is meant for and we
have all this technology to communicate
but we don't listen we don't have lists
we don't have Nuance for nothing
it's like Nuance is the enemy of my
cause and the minute you go against what
I do or what man death to you all and
you're on the other side and we can't
just be like excuse me I have a question
yeah you can't even question and that's
that's crazy because as I was growing up
me being able to learn [__] or be able
to grow
was me being able to question stuff I
remember uh when I was in school they
used to tell me oh there's no stupid
there's no stupid questions and then at
some point the more you grow the more
they assume that you're supposed to be
like everybody else right everybody
wants to be everybody wants to those
same people are saying and you're
they're saying uh don't be afraid to be
yourself
but then if you're someone else or you
just have a question not like them man
they [__] dish you out they're the
same people that do that not just a bit
crazy to me you cannot question you
cannot have new ones I'm not saying that
you're going to be canceled I'm not
going to that side it's just that they
are gonna put you on the side of the
enemy right away and that's not that's
not that's not the the the that's not
really what what happens you might have
some questions and the funny thing is
what I remember I'm not saying that's
exactly what you do but is that in that
direction the people that I thought that
do not have a say in whatever they want
to say are people that are under a
dictatorship and you dictate where the
group goes and nobody asking questions
it leans into the same way I'm not
saying that's what you're inherently
doing and you're exactly that and you're
retiring and I'm not saying that you're
any kind of tyrant like anyone that we
had in history remember Bernie Sanders
when he's on the campaign Trail he was
doing this uh he was doing this uh rally
and then these two black women came on
and stole the mic and he sat there in
the corner cucked and everybody knew
that she was wrong but nobody really
nobody said [__] why because they took
over and they co-opted the direction of
this thing even Bernie on his own
campaign Trail had his mic and his time
swollen and pretty much I think for me
this really solidified how I beautiful
yeah and I'm like bro you ain't got no
[__] spot How You Gonna lead a
country
by two random cities you ain't got
security no that [__] was weird and the
thing that happened is that out of all
the people that you could have cut off
you chose Bernie because he's an
imperfect Ally nope he's an enemy again
because he didn't perfectly aligned with
what these sisters thought a political
uh party should do
he was the enemy and that's what I'm
seeing a lot of and so to be fair to
everyone else we probably play a large
part in that because we criticize this
or we criticize that and sometimes I
think we even criticize things I see on
the left a lot more but that's just
because that's what I belong to and
that's what I'm around way more often
and in my personal life and my lived
experience that's what affects my
day-to-day life I live in a very liberal
City so when I have issues with certain
governmental policies or the way that
things are ran it's generally what
left-leaning people it's not right when
folks are [__] up my life on a
day-to-day basis so that's how I played
on a media standpoint you know I gotta I
gotta own my own part in that [__] but
yeah it just Peaks me it pays me that
someone could just look at you is like
oh you're not part of us it's like who
do you get to decide my values the other
ones the things I vote for the things I
believe in say otherwise the kind of
stuff I donate to the kind of programs
I'm involved in say otherwise what is
your [__] non-important issue of
trans women in sports get to dictate
what virtues belong to the left or not
you get what I'm trying to say so just
like and you know what the craziest part
about this whole thing is people think
that just because I say I don't think
trans women shouldn't be in women's
sports I'm somehow like hentai trans yo
whatever pronouns they want give it to
him whatever Medicaid or like trans
affirming care they need you give it to
them I said that's fine
I got no issue with it and that is
already more Progressive the vast
majority of the population when it comes
to these transitions right definitely
but because I'm not on board with the uh
trans women in sports or I'm not bored
with the whole idea that if you're not
open to being trans people you're
transphobic then I'm already not an ally
or whatever I'm the enemy and everybody
I don't care not being an ally but I
don't have to be an enemy it just seems
like it's very extreme rhetoric and
ineffective for diplomas everybody that
are saying that are for that or
oftentimes people that do not it does
not affect them it does not affect them
or they never been in that environment
you've never been in that environment so
you won't know but whatever it is it is
what it is you can't go about life like
that you know and when whenever we
pinpoint some things that could be
better it doesn't mean that we
inherently hate the things or we hate
that group or anything like that you
know it's to do better in my
relationship if every time my girlfriend
was saying something about how I do
things and be like well you don't love
me anymore like a little no she wants me
to do better so I do better do this do
that it would be better if you do do
this and I do the same thing you know
what you did that you drop the ball on
that whatever let's do better right it's
not because I hate her it's not because
she hates me that's how we grow that's
how I'm able to do to do better if I
look at my parents and we have
conversation same thing they say some
wild [__] I cash them if I see them
watch it they catch me same thing in my
surroundings same thing in my friends I
wouldn't want anybody in my friends
that I go on some wash it and they don't
catch me hey yo bro
that [__] you did the other day that's
kind of wild
accountability doesn't mean I hate the
person doesn't make the person hates me
but that's how we're able to grow also
it helps you said about growth is true
like when you guys silence this kind of
dissonance and you just call it
transphobia you don't actually
strengthen your arguments nah like a lot
of the people who are doing this
advocacy for like trans women in sports
either bring up faulty studies or things
that have been debunked by other studies
and most of the majority of the science
and most of the government bodies so
it's like
you're not even doing a service to your
own cause you're demanding and
bludgeoning people over the head with
guilt to follow what you believe but you
haven't actually taken the time to
assess the criticism and be like hey
this criticism is here how do I debunk
it and if you came to me with better
arguments I'd be open to it but the
truth is even amongst left-leaning
people and Democrats a lot of them are
actually against the trans women in
sports and it's because you haven't made
compelling arguments so that's your job
if you really believe in your cause it
shouldn't be to demand everyone changed
their mind it should be on you to make
iron clad arguments well you got the
translucent [__] shirt on huh well
you got a translucent shirt on yeah it
is
okay I'm sorry why you got a lace shirt
on that slice
a slice you got lace on it you got
lingerie on
he got a luxury shirt on yo yo bro
you're sure to see through I didn't say
see-through translucent and transparent
and two different things okay what's
translucent translucent is that light
goes through it transparent is that you
see through it
that [__] sounded kind of solid
I think I might be losing this one
transparent is that you see through it
friends Lucent allowing light but not
detailed shapes to pass through
semi-transparent let me I want to see
what a translucent shirt is that's what
you just said translucent
[__] that's translucent
shirt you can see everything you can see
shape and [__] because look at the that
yeah there you go that's translucent
that's [__] translucent that's
transparent same thing what are you
doing that's transparent that's
translucent shirts that's what I wrote
yeah
exactly so I want to find some
translucent shirts what's that [__] hold
on what's it what's it that is not holes
[__] yeah that's holes that's mini
holes
[Laughter]
no you got a chance that's not holes bro
you know what that is right that's just
thin fabric that's hold that's thinner
fabric well not thinner that's bigger
holes that's what it is
I could see through it I can see clean I
bet the rain is gone
hey man this is the quality content
y'all asked
he could be right I'm not gonna lie to
you I'm not gonna go pretend hold on I'm
not even gonna go pretend like I know
but I like to argue so here we are
transparent you could see [__] it's like
a glass is transparent you want to know
when I realize I [__] up when you hit
me with the definition that's just how
the technical I said damn this [__]
know some [__] he knows some [__] we are
not equal in this field it's like when
you come on the field right the place
and play a game of football and the
[__] pull out shoes you never
see me yeah all right I thought this was
pickup [__] why you got cleats on the
side of your foot Clips on the side what
are you gonna do run like this [__] I
thought we was just playing but you
can't wait
I just came to play you came in like
it's your job sir calm down you know my
favorite moment is what what [__] put
on the nice shoes and then they play
like trash yeah you like I got nervous
for nothing yeah I thought I was about
to lose some bread
and then he lost some red bottom them
shoes
you made you make me nervous
this is something I want to talk about
because I thought this was probably the
most interesting and more like relevant
topic out of all of us but yeah we
wanted to leave that to you guys how do
you guys feel about this is this a
sentiment you have felt in your own
lives and if so how we want to hear from
you in the comments I do read the
[__]